that was a boring episode for I hate we
didn't find out anything I think when
will stuff happen on this show I know
right can we finally get just a little
bit of information finally then it
reveals shit right mm-hmm I'm praying to
God that like the people watching this
I'm insane the gravity falls being logs
a bunch of you like fuck what they look
at me oh yeah yeah
shaved woodchuck face yes yes yes anyway
um this is on the run
uh what I like about this episode it
starts off with some exposition and then
I think oh it's just gonna be a runaway
story like shit we're gonna get one of
these and then it's just like dumps you
into like this whole plot jump a lot
exposition a good a good mix of a lot of
plot a lot character um this is one
where we find out they're kind of
fugitives just not bad fugitives you
know it's you know what to believe
you know these gems were gonna do
something really bad to the earth they
don't say what according to them I mean
we haven't heard the other judge side
I'm sure um so if I gonna do something
really really bad and they broke off and
said no we're not gonna be a part of
that or a stick with earth and we're
gonna protect it all that stuff it seems
to me what they're doing going around
stopping all these monsters and other
gems and stuff uh and yeah amethyst
especially doesn't sort of like the way
they're talking about it so she was born
out of a cliff vagina pretty much so her
and Steven decide to run away like the
runaway boys or the no home boys that's
what no home boys yeah it's just like
it's some sort of spoof between like the
Hardy Boys and the Boxcar Children
okay so or the Boxcar Children like were
they really unbuttoned oh I dia what
that shows about art that show books see
it was a series of books I think I want
to say it was like written during the
Depression because it's the sort of
thing where they have boxcars and
children traveling like is that the
thing they travel like on the boxcars
and stuff I
they're like Runaways or under Matt okay
I don't think I've touched those books
since the third grade so I want to say
yes that that's what happened and they
solved a whole bunch of mysteries most
of which were
pretty freakin pedestrian okay um like
Holloway they could solve I mean it
makes ya like my group of teens in their
mystery van it's like how the hell are
they the ones s office yet somehow the
police and all these are people the
Hardy Boys in the NC drew always said
that feeling of like oh shit there's
real danger I always seem to remember
that boxcar children there just was not
who stole the pie like that kind of
thing
yeah that kind of like um so anyway so
they run away and amethyst takes Steven
to her home which it turns out is not on
a galaxy far away it's right there on
earth lands on earth and she was mined
apparently and uh do you know how the
orcs would yeah like that was my first
thought was idea look I um no perfected
and amethyst was one of the bad gems
apparently or she came from a place of
like the bad gems and she harboring some
major animosity there's some unresolved
issues going on obviously um and she and
pearl get into a throwdown
yes what's nice animation on that I
could catfight of gemacht proportions
yes and um yeah they says that it's
still her home and she is always seen as
a mistake and pearl says I didn't know
you thought that way I thought you saw
it's like you're the only good thing
that came out of this mistake or
whatever so the more bad she talked
about the more likely watches you're not
a mistake you're just a byproduct of
Amma Thursday yeah um and uh but they
still have a nice little hug and they
realize that their family bottle all the
good stuff uh and then just weirdo edit
at the end where it's like we see it as
we can see a little bit more the
background abuse looks like who and that
it stops what the music's Tim L very
much um now I just think this whole
episode was like soundcheck by tomorrow
to be amazing uh let's do that somebody
out there doing yes
at Stover that's goobie do I just um but
no there's obviously God not only a lot
of plaid all the way but really shows a
nice character between purl and
especially amethyst well I haven't seen
that much of in a bit
so I guess maybe they were gonna
colonize earth or I thought I don't know
like an again we're getting this from
them I mean they were they found these
gems at a site wanted to keep it secret
from Steven Osgood on here I don't I
like it I don't like it it's I find this
a highly suspicious I wonder if it's
like War of the Worlds where they were
always kind of they're like even before
mankind evolve they've just always kind
of been there uh yeah there they will be
my it seems like they were mining more
gems yeah so I'm a they're bringing
chips to life under army of the undead
or something I don't know
yeah um but I love the design of that
whatever the kindergarten which does not
is nothing like our kindergarten
apparently um but just the designs that
play it just looked very threatening
you're kind of waiting for something
that come alive and it never does but I
like that you're I just want to hear
like orc music like junk yeah so do I I
don't
dr. Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim
Jim Jim's but what I uh
whatever damn Jim Jim Jesse Jeff is more
named Jim but not the movie Jim Jim John
um but yeah I think the UH some of the
things I like are very much like you
know when Pearl says you know you can't
defeat me she says I don't care I just I
like this is a Pyrrhic now let me know
if I can get my paralyzes totally
something I would say if I were fuckin
pissed is uh I don't want to fight you I
would want to fight me all of that line
I was like I was great
well in something that I think this
address is pretty well and again I think
this is sort of opening a pearls
character as well is that um which is
something I fall victim to you know I
can be very naive about this stuff is
that there's this acknowledgment of well
I see things a certain way so clearly
you must and
see that with pearl because it's all
about you it is all about me clearly
what's that something I'm not supposed
to see are you wrong anyway um it's very
much you know pearl saw that the more
she was sort of digging into how
terrible these other gems are and where
they come from stuff like that the
better she was making her feel because
she thought well you're the only good
thing that came from this you know
clearly you know that I mean she just
knows that she's the only good thing
comes from it and she doesn't always
feel man she doesn't always think that
to a point where she actually forgets it
if it was even ever really acknowledged
or said you know purchase or took it for
granted that's like oh she she has to
know that um that's really insightful
what do you want what do you think
that's not at her no I'm just like that
was actually insightful it's new
experience oh well thank you aren't you
kind assistance some naive things that
you miss sometimes too
oh I didn't miss a thing except for that
Evangelion reference in the previous
episode I did totally miss dad they say
that in the comments or something yeah
oh what a random thing the real are they
the funny thing is I do want you to be
jokes you robbed Shay
actually bad that actually pretty much
fucking believe Rob would miss it even
reference I am the funny thing is I
normally don't read the comments so I
would have kept missing it but there
were a couple then I just saw them on
your Facebook so I'm I are I was
scrolling through quickly and they're
like he missed the even killing
reference I was like sitting at wracking
my brain and what what a man galleon
reference I was like I totally would
have it I had to keep thinking I was
like okay was the game one where he kept
going through the tinkles to the
challenge of the very end and all lights
up an area goes yeah you did not like oh
oh gee you did I'm like I get it now and
you have no fucking clue what I'm
talking about even a little because you
didn't watch even Gillian I didn't know
should because it's amazing I just hear
it's amazing in the ending is like what
the fuck that's all I hear actually it
was a reference kind of to the yet yeah
I sorta figured um yeah it the funny
thing is I loved even Gillian that went
totally over my head it was until
somebody mention like oh yeah I guess I
wasn't even reference I guess I was
taking it face
they're like granulation but there you
go I mean is something that you just
don't even think about and it's just
like Oh like how could I miss this how
can is this very obvious thing that I
didn't notice um again tying it back to
the episode um
so yeah I think that's something where I
like it again in fact your time CAD does
this to where they really sort of hit
these marks that's like are good for
kids but it's like they really hit for
adults too that's kind of even though I
technically like like gravity falls more
I like the characters better in the
story and the jokes and stuff like that
no fine the one thing that I acknowledge
I'm like nah they got these are shows
have it better is that their messages
are more adult and I like the fact
they're sort of taking these messages
and saying we can start teaching them
young the gravity fall messages are
usually we know the message at the
beginning of the episode and it just
follows through but it's fine because
they have all these are things are great
we're with this one it's uh with this
adventure time that's kinda like where
they go with this what are they gonna
say with this exactly the kernel Falls
are more like Boxcar Children there's a
mystery yeah what was it a from the on
the run the the the no home boys the no
home boys a little more no home boys
yeah I think every every kid I think has
their fantasy of running away I think
adults are killed you're talking about
now - um I mean I think everyone sir has
their way more than fantasy a bit I
think they have a fancy like just
leaving everything behind and starting
anew and just going somewhere the open
road or something like that you know
hunger midlife crisis don't pass this
but I mean why I see you buy a fucking
red Corvette or like a Harley I'm just
gonna sit there and be like I'm gonna
shoot you now and take your car yeah
it's done and blood no it's like it's
something I know I would probably never
do because it's like I like my home too
much of I'm Way too much of a you know I
like my comfy couch I like my comfy bed
abandoned all my shit one that so I love
my shit even Stephens like realization
was exactly like mine I would have been
like you know they make it look so soft
but hey is really itchy I want to sleep
in my own bed yeah we grew up on a farm
for a few years so we can tell
to fight yes it is a and our mouse - yes
dusty really yeah it it it's pretty
fucking unpleasant but there is nothing
Pleasant about it a barn is not pleasant
no a mother busy our yard smell yes and
it's definitely something it's like a
farm is nice and they've all run sucks
it's a sort of smell that you it never
leaves your nose truly yes when you go
to a zoo or heading there per se and you
get that whiff of it your get instantly
transported back and that is the hay
horse piss shit smack it's kind of like
imagine there's somehow a wooden jar
like it's made of wood but somehow
nothing escapes it and you just put some
poor shit in there
like that's pretty much the snow a musty
nasty ass yes but boxcars not much
better
hahaha probably women experienced after
writing many a boxcar yeah solving
mysteries that were pretty easy if my
people are probably just like we stopped
trying to solve this mystery we already
got no I will solve it the only man I
ever saw was which homeless person stole
my goddamn lunch sister that's okay
they paid that's anyway good for you Wow
where we're unloading so much just like
this episode exactly again full circle
so no good episode good like reveal
without again giving away too much uh
you know are still enough mystery in
there but good character building as
well so um yeah I liked it uh good stuff
and I'm sure there's more good stuff in
the way and I hope so yes let's run away
and never look back
no but I'll totally throw you into a
boxcar let's do it wait